the coronavirus pandemic has led to
shortages around the world
and in the early days of the pandemic we
ran into one particularly concerning
shortage
we didn't have enough blood blood drives
across the country were canceled
leading to more than 1 million donations
going uncollected
so when we run low on blood is there a
backup
not yet but researchers have been
working on a solution for the future
by producing blood in their labs blood
can be complex to replicate because it's
made up of different parts
red blood cells that carry oxygen white
blood cells to fight infection
plasma that carries nutrients and
proteins and transports blood cells
and platelets that help your blood clot
a lot of the momentum in the field is
with labs trying to grow their own
platelets
how do they do that they use stem cells
those are cells that have the ability to
make other cells
scientists have previously tried out
different types of stem cells
but there was a huge breakthrough in
2006 when a researcher found
a way to turn mature cells in the body
into a pluripotent stem cell
that is a stem cell that can create
almost any other cell
it's like if you use different kinds of
building blocks to make this big castle
then revert that castle back to a single
block and then you can tweak that block
multiply it and build a completely
different structure
this nobel prize winning discovery
prompted researchers to change their
work so they could use these special
cells
so how do you go from stem cell to
platelet
first you need to grow them into what's
called a megakaryocyte
it's the huge cell that produces
platelets in the body
typically scientists take the
pluripotent stem cells and activate
certain regions of their dna
to coax them into becoming a
megakaryocyte
then they mix the megakaryocytes with
fluid causing the cells to multiply
and finally they produce platelets but
they had difficulty producing enough
platelets
until one research group unlocked a
solution
they created a bioreactor it's like an 8
liter french press which works by
keeping the megakaryocytes moving
and it allows them to produce billions
of platelets
in other words enough for a transfusion
most of this work is currently being
done in labs but these platelets have
been tried out on one human subject in a
clinical trial in japan
right now the technology is expensive it
can cost
labs tens of thousands of dollars to
make one bag of platelets but
researchers have a vision for a more
scalable solution
platelet factories there's hope that in
the future
manufactured blood could help deliver
critical therapies
support areas of the world where the
blood supply runs low
or be used as a backup during global
[Music]
emergencies